you know I've had several calls on the
show this week of people that were stuck
in cars and they had car messes and had
made car mistakes and I just I was just
reading through a report that just it
just depresses me for one it makes me
mad for two and it's shocking for three
listen to this
Americans are seven hundred and eighty
three billion dollars on their cars now
that's bad you won't know it's worse
thirty four percent of that one-third
that's two hundred and fifty billion
dollars approximately is subprime loans
now I don't know if you know what a
subprime loan is it's anything other
than a prime loan a prime loan is a very
very low interest rate at very
advantageous firm but it's only for
people with good credit so what we have
is we don't only have people that are
too broke to buy a car which if you
didn't pay cash for the car you're too
broke to buy the car but not only do we
have people that are too broke to buy a
car but we also have people that are too
broke to even pay their bills on time
that are adding to their debt going
further into debt to buy a stinking car
that's amazing eighty-four percent of
people who bought a car in the last
quarter of 2013 borrowed the money and
they're borrowing more than ever before
the average is up over $26,000 what
they're borrowing to buy a car now you
need to understand a car payment is a
way to ensure that you stay broke if you
live from I'm always going to have a car
payment car payments are a way of life
I'm always going to have a car payment
and I always want a newer car because
that's what's safe and reliable and all
these lies and BS that you believe about
cars and they're all a bunch of crap I
love cars I'm a boy okay but some of you
girls like cars too but you just like
them because you think they're a large
purse but we Americans have a love
fair with our cars I'm not against a car
eighty-four percent of people that
bought a car in 2013
faint financed it and one-third of them
subprime subprime they're paying ten
fifteen eighteen twenty four percent
you've got to be kidding me
you've got to be kidding me well let me
help you with this I will ride a freakin
bicycle before I have in the car payment
car payments are a way of signing up for
middle class and staying there now
there's no shame in being middle class
unless you're so stupid that you just
stay there on purpose because you have
no discipline you have the right and the
opportunity and the ability to win with
money and build wealth in this culture
if you quit doing stupid stuff borrowing
money at 18% or 16% of 15% to buy a car
is way over on the spectrum of stupid
borrowing money to buy car is stupid
borrowing money and 17% of my car is
stupid on steroids baby this is big
stupid with a capital S and then scratch
your head wonder why you're broke
because you work your butt off to give
money to the bank you've ever been in
the bank have you noticed I got better
furniture than you've got have you
notice our building is bigger than your
house how the flip you think that
happened cuz you give all your money
that's how it happened you give them all
your money look in your skyline what are
those towers banks quit giving them all
your money and then scratching your head
wondering why you're broken and whining
and complaining about wealth inequality
Goodson it's unfair the rich get richer
and the poor do what eighteen percent on
their car what stop it
of course you're gonna be poor when you
do that hey when I did stupid stuff
it may be poor too so I look different
not even better matter of fact I did it
with zeros on the end so actually worse
but gosh people really I mean this is
like payday lending for cars it's so
scummy but most of America now feels
like they have to have a car cause
you're real worried about impressing
somebody at a stoplight that you're
never gonna meet 622 dollars a month
over 84 months what are you doing have
you lost your mind stop it
34% of people subprime borrowers
unbelievable
84% of you bought a car you couldn't
afford if you didn't write a check by
the way to buy the whole freakin car you
couldn't afford it
you